[موسيقى]
لقد مررت بعصر تعرف فيه أن
تصور الأفراد السود في
كرة القدم كان جيدًا في قلب المهاجمين ،
وأجنحة جيدة وسريعة ، ولكن ليس
كابتنًا لكل المواد الإدارية ، ولكن
خيبة الأمل في الواقع هي أننا
لم نحقق هذا التقدم  لقد
فقدنا جيلًا من اللاعبين السود المؤثرين حقًا
الذين نشعر بأنك تعلم أنه كان بإمكانهم
جعل مدربين جيدين للغاية ، يفعل ما
تقوله عن عدد اللاعبين السود الذين
خسروا في اللعبة أنه كان
هناك جيل كامل من اللاعبين
محرومين من فرصة
نموذج يحتذى به ، نعم أعتقد ذلك وأنت تعلم أنني
تحدثت إلى العديد من
اللاعبين مثل اللاعبين العرقيين على مر السنين
والذين أرادوا أن
يتمكنوا من الحصول عليها مرة أخرى الذين بحثوا عن
هذا المسار ولم يتمكنوا من رؤية هذا
الدور  النماذج التي يمكن أن تظهر في الواقع
المسار
[الموسيقى]
لقد تحدثنا كثيرًا عن
السكة الحديدية ، إنها سياسة دوري كرة القدم كما
نعرفها في كرة القدم الإنجليزية ولكن
هناك نقاد لها.  ها هم بعض
اللاعبين السود الذين يقولون انظروا
أنني أفضل عدم وجود قاعدة جديدة للغرفة أفضل الحصول
على وظيفة بناءً على مزاياي ولكننا نحتاج إليها ،
حيث تقف بشأن المشكلة الآن
أنا أؤيد أي شكل من الأشكال
تأخذ قاعدة روني ، أفهم تمامًا
النقاد الذين تعرف أن
القاعدة التي تعرف أنها لا تُمنح وظيفة فردية ،
لا ، لا كل ما تفعله القاعدة
هو وضع هذا الفرد في
مكانك الذي يمكنه فيه على الأقل
الخضوع لعملية مقابلة  هذا
هو التوازن
[موسيقى]